Bad information impacts all of us.
Scams threaten all of our finances.
Political misinformation undermines
our democracy.
When it comes to the
coronavirus pandemic,
health misinformation threatens
all of our lives.
In human history, it has never been
so easy to spread misinformation
to millions of people so rapidly.
My name is Laura Walters,
I'm a journalist,
and I have been a victim
of misinformation.
I got a cold call from a new website
looking to publish news content.
Everything seemed very normal,
like any other freelance commission.
I wrote the story on Chinese
influence in New Zealand,
and then I literally thought nothing
more of it.
And about three or four
months later, I got a call.
Turns out that the FBI had actually
tipped off Facebook.
This news organisation wasn't
a news organisation at all.
It was the same troll farm
that meddled in the 2016
US presidential elections.
From there it's been a deep
dive into learning about
how our networks are infiltrated
to try and spread misinformation.
I could have completely
avoided this situation
if I had applied the scrutiny
in the same way that I do
when I'm investigating
a story myself.
If I can show how it happened to me,
maybe I can help other
people avoid it.
It's been a real wild
experience for me.
It's important to remind people
of the dangers of information
and the new ways
that people can share information
that present risks to all of us,
but also the internet as a means
of sharing good information.
Yes, we're all confronted with
more information than ever
which makes it hard to tell
fact from fiction,
but at the same time,
fact-checkers like us
can use the internet and the reach
that we have to correct the record
quicker than we ever could,
and directly to people.
You can verify a story in many cases
by simply typing in
the claim that you're
not very sure of
and putting "fact check" next to it,
for example,
on your preferred search engine.
There's a very good chance
that the top result
will actually take you to one of the
fact checking organisations' website
that has already looked into
that claim.
Fact checking organisations have
looked into well over 100,000 claims
just when the pandemic started.
Within one year, they have looked
at over 10,000 claims
only related to the pandemic.
There were quite a few
stories circulating
that were false, that were offering
very simple cures to the disease,
such as if you inhale steam.
-And that it would cure coronavirus
just seemed completely illogical.
But when people are just overwhelmed
by the amount of information
and they're scared
and they're anxious,
it shows that they
can believe things.
It's interesting, when
we're sort of anxious
we have, on the one hand, a need to
actively go out and find information
as a way of explaining what's going
on, or even to help keep us safe.
But at the same time,
the research shows
we also experience paradoxical
inability to process complexity,
which, all together, means
that when we are anxious
we are even more susceptible
to bad information.
There are tools online to verify,
for example, fake images.
One of them is Google
reverse image search
where you put in an image
and search for that image.
It is a really useful way
of seeing where that image
originally came from.
Something like this would be
a huge news story
so if it's not being reported
by trusted news sources
that might be a clue
that it's not actually true.
Deepfakes is a big concern,
and it's a growing concern, because
it's completely new technology.
The wonderful world of deepfakes.
AI and VFX.
In the future that technology's
going to be perfected
and then we would really struggle
to tell whether that video
is not what it's meant to be.
And so more technology is coming out
that would help curb the spread
of misinformation
in the form of plug-ins
or that you could download
and attach to your browser.
They could tell you what's less
credible and what's more credible.
Algorithms that could help the
social media platforms
to detect automatically
and very rapidly
which stories being circulated
that are not true.
I'm quite hopeful on our ability
to tackle the spread
of misinformation in the future
because more people are aware
of the issue
because AI technology is becoming
far more effective and powerful
in determining what is credible
and what isn't
and then reducing, if not stopping
the spread, of that misinformation.